سلام نتحدث عن اليوم الس 76 للحرب بيان
لافت من كتاب القسام على لسان ابو عبيده
وتفاصيل مهمه في مناطق متفرقه ولكن نبدا
بالقصف الذي نفذته كتاب القسام على تل
ابيب في اليوم الس 76 لهذه الحرب هذا يعني
ان المقاومه لازالت قادره على ضرب العمق
الاسرائيلي ونحن نتحدث عن تل ابيب فنحن
نتحدث عن حوالي 70 الى 80 م عن قطاع غزه
في تطور لافت في اليوم الس 76 لهذا القتال
المتواصل ولكن القتال الميداني في مناطق
متفرقه من قطاع غزه لا يزال حاضرا وبقوه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه منطقه خان يونس تقول
كتائب القسام وسرايا القدس بانها تنفذ
عمليات هجوم وضرب للاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
القسام كما تقول وقتلت خلال الساعات ال 24
الماضيه 17 جنديا اسرائيليا في منطقتين
اساسيتين المنطقه الاولى هي منطقه التوام
في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
وهي من المناطق الاولى التي توغلت فيها
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه قبل حوالي
50 او 52 يوما في اواخر اكتوبر اذ تقول
كتاب القسام اليوم انها قتلت في هذه
المنطقه 11 جنديا وبعد ذلك استطاعت
استهداف بعضوه شواظ طبعا استهدفت احد
جنديا بعد ذلك استطاعت استهداف ثمانيه
جنود كانوا ضمن قوه مسانده للقوه التي تم
استهدافها في البدايه اذا نتحدث وفق اعلان
كتائب القسامه عن مقتل 11د جنديا في منطقه
توان في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من
مدينه غزه المنطقه الاخرى التي تتحدث عنها
كتاب القسام تتحدث عن المنطقه الوسطى في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه للبلده القديمه
لمدينه غزه هذه البلده القديمه لمدينه غزه
وعندما نتحدث عن المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
فنحن نتحدث عن هذا الحي حي اليرموك هذا
ملعب اليرموك الذي نشاهده في الخريطه في
منطقه اليرموك ك قالت كتابه القسام بانها
استهدفت بيتا تحصن فيه جنود اسرائيليون
وقتلوا سته جنود تحصنوا في هذا المنزل
ليعود ليكون المجموع سته في منطقه اليرموك
11 في منطقه نتحدث عن 17 جنديا بحسب اعلان
كتاب القسام بانها قتلتهم بشكل مؤكد
بالاضافه الى القوه المكونه القوه
المسانده لا 11 جنديا مكون من ثمانيه جنود
تم تحقيق اصابات واضحه ومباشره فيهم وثقوا
بين قتيل وجريح بحسب اعلان كتائب القسام
هذا بالاضافه لاعلان الكتائب اليوم بانها
خلال الساعات او خلال خلال تقريبا 50 يو
من بدء التوغل البري في نهايه اكتوبر قالت
كتائب القسام بانها
دمرت 720 اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه متوغل في
في مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه هذا يعني
بحسبه بسيطه ان كتائب القسام لوحدها
استطاعت تدمير حوالي 14 اليه اسرائيليه
يوميا منذ بدء التوغل البري في نهايه
اكتوبر تقريبا في اليوم ال7 او ال8 من شهر
اكتوبر الماضي هذا بالاضافه الى قنص 15
جنديا خلال الاسبوع الماضي وكنا قد شاهدنا
كتاب القسام وقد ادخلت الى الخدمه وفق
اعلانها سلاح الغول وهو اله قنص او بندقيه
قنص م مجهزه ومصنعه محليه هذا يتزامن مع
قصف عنيف شهدته مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه
من اقصى الشمال الى اقصى الجنوب بالاليه
بالمدفعيه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه والمتوج
بالاضافه الى الطيران الذي لا يغيب عن
سماء قطاع غزه في اليوم الس 7ا لهذه الحرب
هذه المعلومات بحاجه الى تحليل وتفصيل
وستكون معك عبد السلام والتغطيه مستمره
اليك